so years ago my family and I had a
really tough tough life change here and
um
we lost my wife here in the city and
and particularly this organization
wrapped their arms around me and my
family and they continue to do so led by
Sam preskey for the ownership here and
people like
I got Blossom and uh
today is would have been my wife's
birthday
and they chose to honor my wife today by
not allowing anybody to to sit in their
seats seats and
when I found out this morning
it really messed me up because
it really speaks to
how blessed I am to do what I do and
work for the people that I work for and
know the people that I know and how much
they care and saying that it's
been really consistent over the past few
years on any day whether it's her
birthday or kids or something along
those lines and for them to do that
today
really speaks to this organization and
this city
and through a tough tough time
God has blessed me and my kids
we're here and we're still rolling and
it's a lot of it is because of good
people like Sam and Ayanna and people in
this organization and in this city and
so
I just wanted to make sure that they
were recognized for that
it's kind of hard enough to make it a
public thing where I think in situations
like this it's good to give gratitude
and be grateful for
good people
hate to Improvement
thank you so much I'm no problem coach